hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for another edition of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you
sorry what's going on everybody how are
ya
oh billy freckles billy freckles went
back to his bad habit
i had gone like a good 40 50 days
without smoking a cigar i
sat down you know what i'll do i'll
smoke a little nub
connecticut rap nice and light oh did i
enjoy that [ __ ] right i'm just like
that's cool it's like half a cigar
a couple days later hey maybe else
one of these aurora gold tube thingies
a buddy of mine yeah i'll try one of
those buddy of mine just gave them a
delicious oh
beautiful cigar i'll have a root beer
with it oh tremendous
couple more days ah maybe i'll have
another one of these [ __ ] nubs
and then this morning i woke up like
what are you doing stop it
so i shut it down i haven't shut it down
totally but you know
it's my only advice i got left um
i'm gonna have one uh maybe on
thanksgiving
do you know what i want to do this year
i really wanted to i've been wanting to
do this for a long time i want to deep
fry
a [ __ ] turkey while somebody from
peta watches no i want to deep fry a
turkey
and uh but the problem is this year with
the whole covid thing right
and all you you guys who don't have
science degrees not listening to the
doctors and medical degrees and you just
you just got it all figured as the big
reset
right so now kovid's you know completely
out of control again you know because
[ __ ] everybody who works in hospitals
you know [ __ ] them they should go and
save your ass
after you went out and did exactly what
they told you not to do because it's not
real
right and all this [ __ ] you're looking
at the internet that's real that's real
you know why
because you need absolutely zero
credibility any credits
any job hire or anything to post
something on the internet so that's
where you want to go to get your
information
the internet um anyway
i'm off my stump here uh i want to deep
fry a turkey but the thing is you know
it's just going to be me my wife my two
lovely kids beautiful kids
um so like what am i gonna do with this
whole [ __ ] turkey
you know what i mean so um
i don't know but everybody goes dude if
you if you [ __ ] deep fried her and i
i watched the videos i got the whole
thing down
you do it in your driveway you go to
costco
you get 10 years supply of [ __ ]
baking soda in case there's a grease
fire
you take the frozen bird you put it in
first
then you fill up the liquid to see how
much liquid you need
okay you don't fill it up to the line
and then stick the bird in because the
bird takes up space and then it goes
over the side
hits that flame underneath ignites and
you're on your wooden deck
and then you spray water at it you burn
down your [ __ ] house
i don't want to do that all right but i
i heard
i heard it through the grape i saw it on
the internet
what i just said everything's [ __ ]
um a lot of it a lot of stuff is
[ __ ] um on the air interweb
um i want to do that really bad but uh
i mean i guess i could get a smaller
bird
you guys send me some emails on this
[ __ ] what if i just got like
half a turkey you know what i mean where
they just give well you want the doc me
too
um i don't know but then you know what's
gonna suck is then i got that deep
[ __ ] fryer what am i gonna do with it
it's just gonna sit there
all year like my christmas tree stand
that i always forget to bring down to
the christmas tree guy and then you want
to stand with that all right give me
another [ __ ] stand
um i think this is like a boat
you know like you don't my my buddy
always told me you don't want to own a
boat
you want to have a friend that has a
boat right and then you show up you know
you bring some [ __ ] beers and
you know whatever else you guys want to
[ __ ] partake in when you go out there
and uh you just have a [ __ ] good time
with it
you know you don't want to be the guy
dealing with the [ __ ] charges
the insurance the barnacles on the
bottom of it now we gotta paint it i
gotta get my captain's license
do i have enough life preservers for
everybody here you don't want to be that
you want to be the guy that just shows
up with the 12-pack
has a medical episode and they got to
fly a helicopter out there with the
floats
and take you back in because you did too
much coke and you freaked the [ __ ] out
um that's the guy you want to be and you
apologize like a week later dude i'm
sorry you know
i got a little crazy when i was out
there i rented scarface the night before
i don't know i apologize right and then
your friend gets okay buddy
it's okay and he lets you come back on
again right
bring a couple of who is next time
instead of the blow over there
um anyway so i'm very excited the
ringing in my ear from that jet
engine has gone down
significantly um i haven't flown i
haven't played drums i stayed away from
all that and i'm just
kind of realizing that i have done a lot
of damage to my ears over
just like podcasting wearing these
[ __ ] headphones i'm not gonna wear
headphones anymore
i'm just gonna be careful and i looked
up a bunch of stuff on tinnitus
and they you know my buddy told me
allegedly they had something over in
sweden
my sweden people what is this patch that
they stick but you stick it behind your
ear
and after like a month it reduces it
three weeks fifty percent
four weeks ninety percent is there any
truth in that
it's on the internet so i'm thinking
this is just [ __ ]
you know and i'm going to buy it it's
not going to work and then i'm going to
call up sweden and i'm going to be like
well
we don't know what you're talking about
[ __ ] you american right and then they're
going to have my [ __ ]
cure tinnitus money while my ears still
ring right
um somebody else told me
that whatever one of the ingredients in
the mushrooms that make you trip
um has been shown to actually help out
with tinnitus so my question is
is there any way to take that out of the
mushrooms because i don't i don't want
to
i'm not wired to trip you know what i
mean
i i got too many monsters in there and i
don't need
to see him coming to life okay and i'm
certainly
not going to listen to all of these
people that take mushrooms and start
once again talking like they have a
medical it resets your brain
you're gonna do you're gonna look at the
universe oh
[ __ ] yeah maybe you were on mushrooms
and that's why this all makes sense to
you
you know just you know what kills me
about that [ __ ]
is you if you get shit-faced
and say a bunch of crazy [ __ ] you don't
wake up the next day being like yeah man
that was my truth right but for some
reason if you
if you hallucinate
then all of a sudden you understand the
universe better now
i'm obviously out of pocket here because
i've never
been tripping before but i also know
that there's an astounding amount of
stupid people
that talk about hallucinating and they
act like they're [ __ ] deep
and you're just listening to going you
sound like the dumbest person i've ever
heard in my life you sound like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] then occasionally i meet
somebody smart
and they kind of say the same thing so
then it's like well then is there truth
in that
and but i'm just talking to a dumb guy
that you know took a trip whatever the
[ __ ] he's supposed to say packed his
bags and left
this reality for a while i don't know
the end of the day is i got two little
kids all right
i can't just like [ __ ] you know
start seeing dragons and [ __ ] or
whatever the [ __ ] it is you see
i have too many responsibilities as i've
said before the
uh the hallucinating
ship has sailed you know i'm going to
dallas in a few weeks but i have shows
every night so like when the [ __ ] would
i do this
anyway but um i'm just wondering is
anybody
anybody else there have a little bit of
tinnitus that they've been trying you
know
avocado toast what works do i rub the
avocado behind my ears
but what i like though now is it it came
it's louder than it used to be which is
upsetting
and a little depressing to me but it's
not as loud
as it was so it definitely came down
and i've just been walking around
wearing earplugs and then there's this
weird thing
that if i'm talking i shouldn't have the
earplugs in because then i hear my voice
even louder in my head so i kind of have
to let that go
you know if i have ear plugs in i use my
electric toothbrush i gotta take those
out so it doesn't like you know
my head is like a it's like a [ __ ]
symphony hall
i got a big round head and it could it's
acoustically incredible
if you have earplugs in but if you have
tinnitus it gets them going again so
i've been trying to be really careful
about that but
so if you got any information i would
really appreciate it i don't know why it
took me so long
to reach out to people all around the
world on this podcast i didn't know you
guys were listening i thought it was
mainly uh
blown away by the response from african
middle eastern countries
uh you know people in asia i mean it's
incredible you guys are all listening
and enjoying this it's it's uh it's
awesome so anyways
so now that i know the whole world is
listening let's talk about some american
[ __ ]
um because that's what we do we [ __ ]
eat and we talk about ourselves
unlike all of you guys and your advanced
nations
right you don't have any [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] goddamn uh part of the world do
you
um oh that'd be a great thing
tell me about the [ __ ] that lives on
your street or from around the world
that's another way to bring people
together hating that [ __ ] jerk off
you know
who doesn't use his driveway and parks
his car in the [ __ ] street
instead you know so now you got to wait
until the person
comes down the hill for you to go up the
[ __ ] hill or around the corner
um that's a pet peeve of mine people who
fill their garages up with [ __ ]
and then don't park in the driveway they
park in the street
uh that says a lot to me about somebody
that says to me that you're lazy you're
selfish
you're disorganized and you're not smart
enough to be living your life the way i
want you to
[Music]
it doesn't take much hey man maybe if
you took mushrooms man you could let
that go
all right cardinals versus seahawks
tonight
oh my god oh my god you guys after all
of these years in the nfl where they
would not give a black guy a [ __ ]
chance
they finally did oh marlon briscoe way
back in the day but now it has come to
this
well you now have if you're [ __ ] good
enough you get to play the position
and because the nfl finally got their
racist heads out of their asses
we got to watch kyler murray lead the
[ __ ] arizona cardinals
against russell wilson i could not be
more [ __ ] excited about this i am a
little disappointed that's a thursday
night game i wish they had a full week
to rest and prepare i hope nobody gets
hurt
but um if you're new to american
football
over there the middle east asia whatever
you're watching these are two of the
most exciting people
playing quarterback right now russell
wilson i think is still the best in the
business
as far as extending the play and his
accuracy on the long ball
is second to [ __ ] none um
i'm i'm finding myself every single week
watching the seahawks and just
enjoying the hell win or lose just
enjoying it i did watch the replay
of the first um seahawks cardinals game
an incredible game
kylo murray is the most electrifying
quarterback
since i would say mike vick michael vick
when he played
in uh atlanta where the second he starts
running like you just you're out of your
seat
right so here's my question
um obviously when i watch the game
there's that incredible play
where the uh the cornerback on uh
the first time these two teams played
picked off the ball for the cardinals
all right um and just took off i mean it
was a pick
six all [ __ ] day long and
dk metcalf like the [ __ ] terminator
he was running a crossing pattern he
wasn't the guy
that this dude was covering he was he
was like
he was already like i don't know how
many yards away and he just took off
[ __ ] running
and it looked like a dad chasing down
his toddler at the airport
i mean i can't believe that was another
professional athlete
at the cornerback position this wasn't a
[ __ ] you know uh a defensive lineman
or something like that some big bell
nose tackle with a big belly and [ __ ]
where you're laughing and cheering him
on as he runs down the [ __ ]
field this was a a a what do they call
it a
uh i don't know one of them those fast
guy positions quarterback
he ran that [ __ ] guy down i was gonna
almost say like it was me running out
there but it was me he would have caught
me if he caught that guy in his
15 he would have caught me on my own 50.
um
so anyway uh i believe this i don't know
what the score was like the
seattle had like seven or ten points
it's the second quarter
there's like six and a half minutes to
go in the second quarter they're down by
like 10 or whatever
so it sets them up first in goal right
it goes to third and goal they don't
make it
at that point kick the field goal take
the points okay
dk metcalf made a great play he took
four points away from you but at least
you get the three points
you're three points closer what do the
cardinals do because
because of these [ __ ] nerds with
their math evidently
they go for it they go for it like
there's six seconds left in the [ __ ]
game rather than six and a half minutes
in the first half
and they don't [ __ ] get it um
you know end of the day cardinals still
won the game but i just do not
understand this whole
madden way of playing football so if
there's people out there that have
obviously
way more experience in playing football
if you could explain to me why they do
this because i remember as a kid
hearing all the great football minds in
the broadcast booth former coaches like
john madden
used to always say you take the points
and then they also the big thing too
and it was it was so [ __ ] true was um
those missed extra points will come back
to haunt you
and that's just one point a missed extra
point in the second quarter somehow at
the end of the game you lose by [ __ ]
one point
and these people are leaving field goal
after field goal
after extra point x the extra point on
the [ __ ] table
um my favorite one is when
they go for a two-point conversion don't
get it
and then they go down you know a little
bit later they they score again go for a
two-point conversion and then they get
it
and it's just like or you could have
just kicked two extra two extra points
knowing that you have like a 99 chance
of doing that
i just feel like uh
if you take all the [ __ ] that's going on
today in the game
all this new amazing stuff with all the
offenses and the excitement of the game
and you combined it with that old school
mentality i wonder if that actually
gives you a better chance of winning
with every [ __ ] time you can come
away from with points you do
as opposed to every it's like watching a
guy who doesn't know how to play poker
and is is pushing his chips and you know
going like all in
all in all in i mean you're gonna
[ __ ] you're gonna bust
it's it look at least as a fan watching
the game listening to all these guys
as i was growing up that's how they told
me now has the game changed so much
is it not that big a deal because the
other teams are doing it i mean i got a
lot of questions here
i really do um the nba draft was
yesterday
uh paul verzi once again excited at this
point even laughs at me going on dude
the nick's got a great guy and you know
it's lol he's like we're on the way back
but um the nba drafts that's got to be
the
the you know of any drafts i would watch
that one because it's so
short what is it like a round and a half
and uh there's also something hilarious
where it's like the nba draft
uh who will you get to watch before they
go to a bigger market team
or a team that beat them last year
[Music]
i [ __ ] i
i ca i don't know in a way it's kind of
cool that you just see these two
juggernaut teams with all which with
seemingly
most of the stars in the league but
i don't know man it just i i like i like
it's
it's not as bad as i'm making it seem
but there is just something
chicken [ __ ] about that you know
the [ __ ] oklahoma city thunder should
have got a rematch with the golden state
warriors and they should have seen if
they could beat him
you know what i mean all of these
[ __ ] guys
right now do you realize the new orleans
pelicans right now
should be an odds-on favorite
to win the nba title next year and
instead
they're just rebuilding again getting
another new star
like what like i said zion zion was it
zion miller like where where is he gonna
end up there's no [ __ ] way that guy's
gonna be a pelican his whole career
you know is john morant gonna stay in
memphis how long is he gonna stay there
as good as he is as he's watching
everybody else going to la to [ __ ] stars
start their own you know [ __ ] i don't
know swimwear line
and and and and win a [ __ ]
championship um
i got to stop picking on the lakers
because it's because i'm a celtic fan
it's going to seem like i'm biased or
like the
i don't know i can't get in too much
with the warriors
the warriors i was fine with until uh uh
durant went over there then it was just
like dude what the [ __ ]
it's like you're watching a batman movie
and the joker ties up batman what will
happen to our caped crusader
he's just gonna [ __ ] join the joker
not only is the episode over the series
is over
he became a bad guy boo
where where where i'm an old sports fan
um but you know i like to think you know
you know the asian culture is smart
enough to learn from their elders so you
know i'm an old bald man right now so i
think some of you young whippersnappers
with your fantasy football teams maybe
you gotta listen
okay keep your snarky little [ __ ]
comments to yourself
and maybe educate yourself kid i don't
know
uh but i am i taste right now i am all
in with the [ __ ] nfl
i am [ __ ] all in i'm having the best
[ __ ] time
uh watching i can't remember the last
time i had this much fun watching the
nfl and i think
the main thing is is i'm off the road
and i can watch and i've been a [ __ ]
nerd
i go on espn site like every other
[ __ ] day
checking out who the leaders are seeing
who's got the best defense
um who's leading the league in
interceptions trying to get to know all
these players names because
i haven't really known a lot of players
names for a good 15 [ __ ] years i got
so goddamn busy
um in a good way but it's been exciting
to actually
uh and people always tell me play
fantasy football you'll [ __ ] know
almost everybody in the league um
and i was going to play this year after
years of [ __ ] on it
um but i just i just didn't get around
to it in time all right let's speaking
of getting around to something let's do
our reads here for the week
let's do our rex reads here for the week
all right um
rex reed two mean too mean to give a ten
let's name some famous reads
rex reed willis reed
and that guy reads something that played
mr brady
how the [ __ ] did i forget his name barry
williams
right uh mike lucanland
eve plum susan olson
the hell is maureen mccormick
christopher knight
and b davis florence henderson
[ __ ] what is his name i thought his name
was reed
anyways helix everybody
uh look i know some of you are sleeping
on saggy old mattresses at night
and you deserve better than that give
yourself an upgrade
with helix sleep everyone's unique
i never saw a fat guy like you the fats
hanging over your belt in a different
way
and helix knows that
we've all eaten our poison food here in
america and it's given us all weird
shaped bodies
wouldn't it be great if there was a
mattress that could just conform around
all of your mistakes
uh they have several different mattress
models to choose from
soft medium and firm
just take their quick two minute quiz
online and they'll match you with the
mattress that's perfect for your body
type
and sleep preferences this is uh helix
finds the right mattress for you
you you you uh whether you're a side
sleeper
i'm not even talking to you a stomach
sleeper high
or you run hot yeah i didn't pay my
taxes
or cold who sleeps cold uh they'll find
the mattress perfect for you
the best part they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights
risk fee free gross uh they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it oh
jesus but trust me you will helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
that's up to 200 bucks
off and free pillows at helixsleep.com
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com oh look who's back
just in time for the thanksgiving
weekend it's all
zip
businesses have had to be flexible this
year
like that [ __ ] up the street they've
had to be flexible
from working remotely to pivoting their
business models
for long-term survival and growth share
some of your own examples
or the following well yeah [ __ ] i've
been doing [ __ ] stand-up on patches
of grass behind motels
i do stand up in parking lots i can
actually now watch a crowd driving in
looking at the crowds and i can judge
the crowd too many prius says
you don't want too many priuses you
don't want too many big trucks you want
a nice [ __ ] mix
uh okay that's my experiences uh
restaurants are moving their dining
outdoors and adding takeout and catering
um what is the porn industry doing do
they move that leather couch outside
some consumer packages a packaged good
company
have shifted to focus more on surface
cleaners or personal hygiene products
major retailers are now selling face
masks we get it people are changing
if you're in charge of hiring your
business these pivots have made your job
even more challenging especially
if you have to hire for brand new roles
thankfully
there's one place that you can always
count on to make hiring faster and
easier
ziprecruiter.com when you post a job on
zip
yeah it gets sent out to over 100 top
job boards with one click then zip
recruiters powerful technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job and
actively invites them to apply it's no
wonder that for the fat
employers who post on zip
uh get a quality candidate within the
first day see for yourself right now you
can try zip recruit for free at
ziprecruiter.com
slash bird that's ziprecruiter.com spell
out burr b-u-r-r
um let zip recruiter take hiring off
your plate
so you can focus on growing your
business go to zip recruiter.com
burr that zip
hey recruiter uh the smartest way to
hire
oh look who's back honey
imagine this you make a list of gifts
you're gonna buy for the holidays and
then someone randomly gives you the
money to help you buy one
sounds good i don't know it sounds a
little scary what does this person look
like they wearing a fur coat do i have
to do stuff for this
uh well that's that's what honey is
doing they're helping pay
for one million dollars worth of gifts
what a bunch of good shits over there
huh
you're probably wondering is this the
same honey that automatically searches
for promo codes online
that would be amazing if you thought
that because that perfectly sets up the
next line
yes yes it is with honey
honey oh honey how could you
you can also make a list of all the
holiday gifts you want from certain
stewards
and honey will email you when the price
drops on anything on your list
just add honey to your computer create
a free account and throw some holiday
gifts on your drop list for a chance to
win
honey will randomly select winners and
give them the money to help buy
something on their list
please talk about the gifts you're going
to add to your drop list
and want honey to help you pay for talk
about the items but not
specific sites please jesus christ
that's a lot of
uh well i don't want to say what if my
kids listen to this podcast um
i'm sending to some suggestions to santa
claus
for a couple of things and uh
my daughter really likes bikes
and i'm not gonna say this [ __ ] because
i don't need you [ __ ] weirdos trying
to [ __ ] send me some [ __ ] don't send
me any [ __ ] don't ever send me any [ __ ]
all you need to do is just [ __ ]
listen okay to the goddamn podcast all
right don't show up my shows
trying to be a secret santa all right i
tell [ __ ] jokes for a living i don't
need any help i'm here to help you
with my ignorance and my jokes okay um
yeah i got a bunch of [ __ ] that i i'm
gonna
okay for my laugh um i'm gonna get her
something shiny
all right because broads like something
shiny
broads want to see you take a nice
[ __ ] chunk
out of your paycheck so they can feel
secure
and they don't care if there's some
one-armed baby digging it out of the
[ __ ] ground
so that's what's on i'm sorry
mandatory no purchase necessary you need
a paypal account to redeem the prize
only valid in the us giveaway ends 12
21 2020 get honey for free
at jointhoney.com that's join
oh no it's join honey h-o-n-e-y
dot com b-u-r-r
all right so would you guys like to hear
a stand-up comedian who really doesn't
get to do much stand-up anymore's
prediction
on a sport that he never played
organized past the third grade and he
only lasted for a month
um tonight um i gotta tell you you know
the last time the
uh the last time the [ __ ] cardinals
won
all right seattle who did they who did
they lose to they lost to the bills last
week no two weeks ago lost to the bills
i want to say they lost another one
they've been on a bit of a losing streak
i think pete carroll is one of the best
head coaches of his era and i think that
they go in and they get it done let's
see what the spread is
will you pick against the spread bill
will you put your [ __ ] joke
money where your [ __ ] freckled mouth
is let's see here
cardinals come on you [ __ ] [ __ ]
cardinals
verse i wrote arnold what the hell just
happened
cardinals verse
seahawks spread
oh degenerategambler.com
what am i doing who is this who am i
talking to
what the [ __ ] was that where did that
voice just come from
hey what are you doing i'm checking the
spread out
who is this what the [ __ ] was that
is my podcast haunted what is that was
that my phone that was my phone
i don't have my phone with me
is that my tinnitus is there a little
[ __ ] crazy woman in my ear now
hey what are you doing all right let's
get to the spread here
i'm not gonna lie to you that was really
[ __ ] creepy wait let's see all the
things i have
my inbox cast insurance for efforts for
family in live
reads there's no and then the cardinal
spread
all right let's just go back to this all
right seahawks first cardinal spread
seattle given three
is there really a home field i guess
that really isn't anymore
you know what you know what seattle has
such a terrible defense though but i
think you know something pete carroll
is a good enough coach that as bad as
that defense has been they're going to
slowly get better
um they need this win
and i just think russell wilson has a
little more experience he's got those
incredible receivers
i got to go i'm giving the three i'm
taking the seattle seahawks
all right i'm picking the seattle
seahawks
all right that is the deal um
okay that is the uh that's the podcast
uh
this monday coming up i'm doing another
show from the troubadour
and there's going to be automatic
autographed posters
and uh that type of stuff i'm really
going to try to help these live venues
out
i'm also going to be reposting a thing
that um vinnie brand from the stress
factory sent me which is
it's we're trying to save our stages um
you know so bands and all the live [ __ ]
that you like to see that it doesn't all
go away
and just become you know comedy i don't
know i don't know what the comedy club
maybe
just all improvs nothing against the
improvs but
you know if you need a bunch of
different other the punchlines
hilarities in cleveland
uh gotham comedy club in new york city
these are my favorites right
uh uh caroline's comedy
comedy club um uh what else what else
punch line in atlanta zany's in
nashville zany's in chicago
i love them all kickers out in michigan
the skyline cafe in appleton wisconsin
the funny bone in saint louis
oh [ __ ]
was that [ __ ] crazy when i used to
work in kansas city
it just totally went blank
i don't know i don't know there's so
many great comedy clubs
side splitters in tampa
um
the go bananas ones stress factory
all of these all of these people helium
all of these people
are the reason why all the comics that
you like
are funny because they gave us the stage
time so um
i haven't gotten to bans and all of that
type of [ __ ] so i hope uh
this thing passes and stuff and i'll be
posting about it if you can just
try to annoy a congressman or whatever
the [ __ ] you're supposed to do so it
gets passed
all right that is the deal everybody
have a wonderful weekend you [ __ ]
and uh enjoy the podcast from the
troubadour
uh be on video too all right this uh
this monday thank you very much
and uh god bless you oh wait enjoy the
music that andrew themis picks out and
you get a bonus half hour of a thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
from a thursday a year ago or i don't
know how he does it all right bye
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
november 19th 2012.
um what's going on how are you i am
in my apartment in new york city and i
think i am as well
miked as i've ever been i bought some
new device
the one that i uh actually ari shafir
showed me when i did his uh skeptic tank
podcast
and um i don't know how to shut off the
external microphone so i'm using a
microphone like i'm [ __ ]
michael douglas i got on my headphones i
got two more stereo like
if you can't [ __ ] hear me this week
if somebody says ooh the pool case was
too quiet
all right maybe you need to go get
miracle ear do they still
sell that miracle ear can't they like
[ __ ]
grow an ear outside of the body at this
point can't they like grow one in a
petri dish
is that what they're working on right
now i mean if they can grow the outside
at this point you know it was years ago
years ago they they showed that unlike
the local news
right after some old lady you know who's
made jam for the last 70 years just
[ __ ] died
oh they usually do that in the end no
they wouldn't now if she died they'd do
it earlier but if she was still alive
she's been making a jab for 70 years and
she's still going oh my god that was
some wonderful jam yes it was
we'll [ __ ] later um
anyways um if this is too loud if this
is [ __ ] up it's just going to be this
one week i just got to go find some tech
person i'm probably tomorrow morning
by the time you're listening to this um
i'm gonna be doing the opium anthony
show
uh uh tomorrow morning and
i'm gonna talk to no danny boy the
lights are
calling uh whatever i'm gonna uh i
really should know
the words today you know does anybody
know the [ __ ] words to that you know
doesn't everybody just know oh danny boy
the lights
right that's like knowing the second
verse to like god bless america
no not that one it's one of those songs
one of those songs everybody just sang
sings the first verse one of those
patriotic songs
and then you never hear the second verse
so number ever looks at the lyrics to
the second verse and then when they
finally look at it that's the most
sexist racist
[ __ ] ever you know
and then they do something about it on
tv should we get uh
the racial slur out of the second verse
or is it part of
the american fabric you know
and then everybody on cnbc and ms all
the liberals sit there go we definitely
have to get rid of it
we should trash white people in the
first verse to make up for what's said
in the second verse
and then everybody on fox news goes you
know i don't see what the problem is
uh they really they say that word to
each other uh i have a red tie on
you know who watches that [ __ ] who still
[ __ ] watches that [ __ ] and just
thinks that any of those people have a
[ __ ] flying i don't know what the
expression is to have any idea what
they're talking about
do you realize how much [ __ ] is going on
in the world and then what do you do
what do those guys do other than just
sit there
and just wait for the [ __ ] the
teleprompter thing to come on
or the incoming news do they still have
that old technology where that thing
types forward and backward
it's coming in you know
incoming news over in england according
to this computer
that some [ __ ] person wrote into
six thousand [ __ ] miles away
evidently this happened
i don't believe any of it i mean i
believe it
i believe a lot more of it now that i
travel that's one of the greatest things
about traveling when you actually see
big ben you're like wow it really exists
this wasn't just made up you ever have
like that paranoid thought that maybe
your town or maybe like your state
depending on how much you've traveled
like that's all there is
and if you just kept going you'd
actually run into that like that [ __ ]
atmosphere that you can't like walk
through you ever have thoughts about
that
well i have and i'm not going to be i'm
not going to
be made to feel that i'm less than you
because you didn't
okay before you start judging me during
this holiday week
what are you guys doing for the holidays
you having some turkey
some [ __ ] beef jerky white people
with the mashed potatoes black
people with the [ __ ] sweet potatoes
right jewish people do you guys sit well
you don't sit this one out you guys set
out christmas
you guys have chinese food right it's
the least we could do give you that one
holiday jewish people hook you up in
september
you barely even have to work in that
[ __ ] month thanks to those people
um i should have given them a shout out
a shout out a late
shout out to jewish people in september
thank you for those two or three mondays
i always forget if it's two
three i know it's one
is that the month right labor labor
labor day almost this day
flag day and then there's uh horatio
sans day what the [ __ ] is it called
yom kippur you know i'm kipper
i know what it is but thank you for all
those mondays i've had off
or is it a tuesday i don't know i don't
the [ __ ] it is
i don't know what it is but this at
least my world my business shuts the
[ __ ] down
on those days and i've never said thanks
so during the week of thanksgiving
thank god i'm giving thanks to jewish
people on those
two three one seven mondays that i have
off
and uh there's only four go [ __ ]
yourself um
in september all right so anyways i
worked at the john lymon center for the
performing arts
on saturday night and uh had a great
time
paul versey went up and [ __ ] leveled
the place
a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm gonna lose another
opener i already lost joe derosa
you know he took off to the the richer
fields of headlining
right i can't get that bastard to open
for me anymore
he's too big of a superstar but you know
i caught him in the dip
the teen idol sensation i caught him
between his his
um his initial success
when he was uh and i think he first
broke on dance fever i can't remember
what
and then when disco was out he had a
rough time
and a lot of people don't know this uh
derosa was actually
offered john travolta's part in pulp
fiction and he turned it down
because uh you know he was still um what
do we say in the business joe was
suffering from exhaustion
during that period and he had to go away
[Laughter]
so whatever now he's back to headlining
and uh
so now verzi's opening for me so i'm
like all right you know i can get some
miles out of this kid this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is killing so hard
they're not doing just the regular
clapping in the end of it they were like
whistling whistling's the next level of
of of killing if someone takes the
effort to just not sit there and you
know clap in their [ __ ] hand
they gotta actually bring their dirty
fingers to their mouth they probably
went to the bathroom
they don't give a [ __ ] about the
bacteria right
and they actually whistle for you when i
hear that i i got i got
maybe another eight months
so if you want to see the legendary
tandem of paul version myself on the
road you better come soon because uh
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is killing so
anyways we were at uh was it southern
connecticut university
did i say it right i don't know what um
it was open to the public so it was a
college gig but it wasn't really a
college kid we were actually at the john
lyman center for the performing arts
that was on that campus and it was
mainly
you know uh people who had already
graduated college uh which made me feel
comfortable actually me and rosie were
both nervous because
you know he's 10 years younger than i am
and i'm actually sitting there going
like okay an incoming freshman was
born in 1994. [ __ ] me
i was already doing comedy two years two
[ __ ] years
what am i going to talk to this person
about you know
what what i haven't done a college gig
in years i don't know people say you
should do them to keep your your
i was actually talking something about
this the other day like how you stay
relevant
as a performer as you you can't once you
start selling tickets and you have
a fan base you can't just do those shows
you have to keep going down to the
comedy club where it's a hundred people
who just showed up that night could give
a flying [ __ ] who you are
and whether you're funny or not and then
you can stay current
but if you just get your crowd and you
just keep performing to them
as you get older they get older and then
one day they start [ __ ]
dying or something and then that's it
you're standing out there this old
[ __ ] guy in a wrinkled brown suit
it's terrible this [ __ ] business that
the back nine is brutal
the back nine is brutal that's why i'm
[ __ ] i gotta do something
i gotta get my two pistols and learn how
to hunt and freeze an elk
okay come see my act i'll explain the
rest of that
but anyways uh what was really
interesting was this um the john lennon
center for the performing arts
was um a stone's throw
from yale university now i've never been
there i've been to
harvard i've done a show at princeton
dartmouth and i've walked by the one
here that's in new york i forget what
it's called
on the way to some ladies
apartment back in the day when i was a
stud
back in the day way back in the late 90s
when old billy redface first came to the
[ __ ] city
right looking like richie cunningham
how i ever got laid back then was just
fine i had to get on the stage and
[ __ ] jump around i had to
what else was i gonna do sit there
looking like a [ __ ] puppet
um anyways
but i've never i've never been to yale i
know i drove by i had no idea where it
was at
evidently it's in new haven connecticut
and uh believe me i've heard some [ __ ]
about connecticut
you know what i mean i definitely have i
know there's a lot of uh blue blood
money there
money and i know that there's uh
oh [ __ ] you know what they just reminded
me of i finally figured out a
way to work in the so-called white man
into my act
i was walking my dog god damn it
somebody sent me a tweet
just write the so-called white man and
let me just have to think about that
where the [ __ ] it would go in
god damn it i was gonna do it last night
[ __ ] um anyways
so i've heard a lot of [ __ ] about
connecticut
that you know there's a you know all
that jp morgan money the blue bloods
the guys you know who like they their
kids haven't worked for [ __ ]
generations
haven't worked since like their their
their initial
uh since that meeting on devil's island
they haven't [ __ ] worked
there's some clan members higher level
no southern accents
you know pushing the pawns around i've
heard about that
i've heard that there's a mix of
patriots and giants fans and then i
heard that there was uh
some rough areas of hatford i definitely
heard that but i never heard about new
haven
so i don't know i figure it's it's an
ivy league campus
i figure it's going to be cool to walk
around or whatever
so anyways i'm like you know what i know
that the yale
bulldogs play in an old stadium just
like avid
i want to go look at it so i looked it
up on wikipedia and said the yale bull
they're claiming is actually the
original bowl in this country
and that all the other bowls looked at
that bowl and said wow we want to build
one too and that's how you got the rose
bowl the [ __ ] cotton bowl and all
those other bulls
that's and then from that they took the
name bowl for the bowl games because
they all played in those [ __ ]
stadiums
and then from there the super bowl took
the ball name from that so it all goes
back to this so i'm like well [ __ ] me i
gotta go see this thing
so i look on my map my little google
maps i see it's a mile and a half away i
hate going to the [ __ ] gym
right i have my banana and apple for
breakfast i'll go [ __ ]
full of fiber i'll go take a walk down
to the yale bowl
go check this [ __ ] out it's a
mile and a half away
i'm in an ivy league i'm on an ivy
league campus this this
how can i go wrong right i got about two
blocks in there's an amazing thing where
you suddenly as a white person realize
that you're walking into the hood
there's those subtle signs you know
that make you nervous first thing you
see is a probably a check
cashing place you know what i mean
funeral home
baptist church you know less white
people and you start going [ __ ]
i'm thinking well it's only a mile and a
half away how bad can it [ __ ] get
plus it's during the day so i never had
a problem during the day during the days
the regular people it's at night
right around seven o'clock i've always
said when that second shift comes out
the hustlers the zombies and all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's when you don't want
to be there
but uh you know you might catch a couple
of those guys coming home late you know
what i mean
so i'm [ __ ] walking through there and
uh i gotta admit i got about six blocks
in and i was waiting
i felt like i was in an episode of the
wire like i was waiting for omar
hey to come walking by with this [ __ ]
gun it was crazy
i also figured out why black people walk
so slow
when they're walking down the street i
get it because when you walk
slow you look like you're not nervous
okay if you're walking fast like i was
you look like either
uh a narc or a [ __ ] victim
you look like you're scared people just
was staring out of just my [ __ ] red
face i think i would i really freaked
out a lot of people because there was
not nobody down there that looked like
me
so i finally got through all this
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i get down to the yale
bowl because i want to look at this
thing thinking it's going to look like
the one that
happened right that's basically a ripoff
of uh
what is that place over there in italy
what yeah the place where they threw all
the christians to the lions
and that fat guy who was balding and
he'd do the thumbs up
thumbs down wasn't pontius pilate he
took out the hippie
julius caesar who the [ __ ] was it the
roman colosseum so i thought it was
going to look like that
so i show up to this thing it's dug into
the [ __ ] ground all i can see is
these entrances
and that have gates in front of them and
above them is just grass i couldn't see
a [ __ ] thing
so then i had to turn around and i had
to walk right back through the hood
and i was way less nervous the second
time because i knew with each step
i was getting closer to my hotel
it's weird how that works then i started
looking around and people looked a lot
more friendlier because i was a lot less
nervous
and you know what i think that's one to
grow on
hey you know what's funny is i actually
want to go to a
harvard yale game in at the yale bowl i
want to do that because
i started thinking about how many future
presidents
sat in the yale bowl or at least
candidates
you know what i mean george w bush was
in there
as was that other [ __ ] guy that ran
against him in 2004
john kerry you know what i mean they
might have done keg stands together so i
just want to look at drunk kids out
there and be like maybe someday that's
going to be my guy who's
allegedly my leader you know
and maybe in the harvard yale game when
they're not giving each other [ __ ] and
throwing their hankies at each other i
can actually hear
you know about the next illuminati
meeting
hey you know i'm always bitching about
the population problem and how they
never [ __ ] bring it up in the
presidential campaigns you know what i
think they bring it up i think they
bring it up on that that bilderberg
group gets together
i think they talk about the real
problems you know
when they all get together and be like
all right what is the most
what is the easiest way to get 7 billion
down to 500 million you know what i mean
as they sit there eating like [ __ ]
lobsters and [ __ ]
then who [ __ ] serves them i bet they
get i bet when
you're a waiter for them when you come
walking into that that group when you
bring in
whatever their [ __ ] escargot and all
that [ __ ]
i bet they all just shut the [ __ ] up the
second you come in or they pull down
some different map
and if you accidentally see something
like uh that you're never heard from
again
am i slowly losing my mind i don't
[ __ ] know anyways this is the monday
morning podcast everybody and uh as you
know
as i stated numerous times um i've
started a podcast network we're just a
mom and pop store at this point like i
said eventually we're gonna be blogging
putting up video but it's called
allthingscomedy.com
and uh it's sort of a co-op like what i
live here in new york
uh live in here in new york and
um you know we kind of it's you know
by addis for artists so we're trying to
we're trying to do uh
you know what's funny about this whole
all things comedy is i was just gonna
say like we're gonna try to have like
this whole hippie commune thing and i
just saw this whole thing on
jonestown so hopefully we don't all like
[ __ ] drink the kool-aid
but um anyways we've got a two new
podcast
um we're adding the naughty room and the
uh the bone zone
um which are absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious podcasts and uh we'll probably
take away listenership from mine
but i'm okay with that you know what i
mean
[ __ ] um actually brandon walsh is one of
my favorite uh can i even say up and
coming well probably because you guys
don't know who he is but he's been
around for a while i shot a failed pilot
pilot with him a long time ago and we
improved
through this whole uh this whole scene
together just had a great time you know
what i mean
just a [ __ ] there's nothing better
than when you're with somebody who knows
they're [ __ ] funny because then they
they don't jump all over your [ __ ] and
then you can relax and you can actually
play off each other it's when you're
[ __ ] getting a scene
and there's some [ __ ] that just tries to
[ __ ] box you out
me me me me me me and you starts
treating you like a lamp that's when
it's not fun
all right anyways
so let's get on with this what the [ __ ]
am i gonna talk about this week how far
into this thing am i what am i what am i
what am i 18 minutes in
my [ __ ] hot ass goddamn apartment
i told you guys a long time ago when my
apartment is so hot and it's not because
i'm in it
hey um
it's because somebody in this building
either their kid got sick or they got
sick i don't know if they're still sick
but evidently unless it's [ __ ] 90
degrees in here
they're gonna get sick again so
everybody in the building has to
[ __ ] suffer instead of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] just buying a goddamn space
heater
they just cranked i said it's drying out
my floors
i swear to god i could i could catch
[ __ ] malaria
in my apartment it's disgusting so
anyways
the [ __ ] was i gonna talk about did you
guys watch any football this week
did you watch you watch the patriots
scored 59
[ __ ] points against the colts but i
got to tell you something how great does
andrew luck look
you know i knew he threw i know he threw
a couple of pick sixes but whatever he's
a rookie that's gonna happen
and he didn't have this this freaked out
look on his face
he threw a pick six and he was like [ __ ]
you know like
that guy's is gonna be uh i'm not saying
anything you don't already know and uh
kudos to the indianapolis colts
huh did they play that the end of peyton
manning
they played that out perfectly you know
they probably knew we had another two
three years but what are the odds
you're gonna you're gonna go from peyton
manning to a guy as good as andrew luck
do you realize how what up what a smart
move that was
that's like in those cartoons when
someone's falling down the cliff in the
phone booth and right before it crashes
they step
out that's basically what they did you
know in the short run yeah they [ __ ]
themselves i guess
you know peyton's starting to click with
the broncos i i like the broncos to
possibly go to the super bowl going out
on a [ __ ] limb there as every other
team is injured
um not really i'm joking about going out
on a limb but um
you know i know it was what was it 59 to
24 gives a [ __ ]
that kid that kid can throw in that kick
and play and uh
i really hope the patriots i can't even
get myself to say this
because it's my quarterback so i won't
even say it out loud but at some point
the person with that cute little dimple
in his chin
is not going to be quarterback anymore
for the patriots and i hope we're lucky
enough
to go from that to a guy as good as
andrew luck that is the [ __ ]
that's it's very rare that that happens
i would probably say the greatest one
that i ever saw
was the 49ers going from joe montana
to steve young other than that uh
not even the dolphins they went from bob
greasy to like don
strzok before dan marino came in and
then dan marino
his career ended and then where the they
haven't had anybody
joey harrington from the lions
who the [ __ ] have they had
chad pennington from the jets i always
thought that that guy could play he just
could never stay healthy
i mean the [ __ ] jets went from joe
namath to nobody
they're still waiting for the next joe
namath
that's how amazing it is and how much
you [ __ ]
freak out when you when you get the real
deal i guess the patriots went from drew
bledsoe to tom brady
you know and i know bledsoe gets a lot
of [ __ ] but i mean that guy was uh
he was up there right he's got the
[ __ ] yards
to prove it
no it's [ __ ] unreal look at the
cowboys
cowboys went roger starback
and then they had that long low then
troy aikman came in
and now they're in another they're in
like a [ __ ] 20-year well now wait how
long did troy aikman play
he played the like uh 2000 maybe and
they're still waiting
although tony romo is not as bad he's
not as bad as people say
bill are you gonna make any of this
[ __ ] funny you're just gonna sit here
and talk about how you remember
quarterbacks all right
all right already um could you hear that
could you [ __ ] hear oh jesus christ
another person telling me they lost the
house in a storm
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] all right there's
another thing to give thanks for
but that didn't happen to me god damn it
um
you know what the great thing about
being a comedian is though you can
actually do a bunch of benefits
and uh i've actually gotten some offers
out on the west coast to do something
i got to jump on one of those i gotta
jump on one of those what the [ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] going on you
know you realize i don't even watch the
news anymore
i'm just so fed up with it i don't know
if i'm fed up with it or i'm so out of
my [ __ ] mind they can't even relate
to it anymore
i just sit there yelling tv ah that's
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i don't [ __ ] know you know
what let's get let's get to a goddamn
mom
let's get to a [ __ ] oh how about a
big shout out to the nhl they're
actually thinking about taking a couple
of weeks off
they just can't come to a [ __ ]
agreement so they're gonna take a couple
of weeks off you know what i'm gonna do
i i i
i'm done with them i'm [ __ ] done with
them you know every sports fan says that
and then they get all excited when they
come back but [ __ ] them i'm bi i'm
getting the nba league pass i've
actually been watching the celtics
for the first time in forever we're
actually younger
and uh i like the way we're playing i
like the way we're playing
and i like every [ __ ] team in the
league
including the knicks just as long as
they beat the lakers
that's it i'm old school i don't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] about the heat
there's still an expansion team to me
uh good for you with your two little
banners
you know i hope you get some more
banners so when the air conditions
turned on and it starts waving
it dries out all the [ __ ] botox
around courtside
how about that how do you like that that
[ __ ] creepy ass town that miami is
i'll tell you for as much [ __ ] as
hollywood gets for the old guy with the
trophy wife
you've never seen it until you go down
to miami beach
and you see these [ __ ] 60
[ __ ]
65 years old 58 maybe at the youngest
with their linen on linen
matching outfit and those brown [ __ ]
loafers
no sandals that look like that face mask
of that guy in the giants
who's just sick of having people poke
him in the face so he basically has a
gerbil cage on his face
though those kinds of sandals those rich
guy sandals
probably made in havana kind of sandals
those guys
65 [ __ ] years old balls hanging down
the side
of their linen pants inside leg of
course let's not get disgusting
right and and they're sitting there with
like some [ __ ]
19 year old it was unreal
it's [ __ ] unreal it's a disgusting
disgusting thing that's going on down
there
you know but they got enough money to
cover it up
how is that legal once you're of legal
age that you could be
58 with a [ __ ] 19 year old climbing
on a [ __ ] 19 year old
right she's into all this new music you
don't know
you're sitting there putting on [ __ ]
uh glenn miller
moonlight serenade they don't know what
the [ __ ] it is that they feel like
they're in the little rascals movie it's
just disgusting
and awesome all at the same time just
depending on what side of the ball
you're on
let's be honest so anyways yeah i'm
becoming a big hoop fan i actually
watched some of the knicks game today
with uh paul version what about the
[ __ ] knicks seven and one
go listen to paul's [ __ ] podcast he's
gonna be freaking out about that
telling you the next kid um
he still says kid and yeah boy when he
[ __ ] texts
he's really starting to show his age but
only in this texting all right here we
go
some uh some questions for the week hey
bill how do i tell my wife
i'm an atheist bill i have the greatest
wife in the world
and we have two wonderful daughters this
is starting off like a horror movie
you know what i mean how it's always
like nice there's always like leaves
falling in a gazebo
but there's just that hint of creepy
music remember they used to do that back
in the 80s when they
couldn't just depend on special effects
they actually had to build suspense
that's how this is look at this guy he
has a great he's a great he is the
greatest wife in the world everybody
and he has two wonderful daughters uh
there's a problem though uh she is a
devout christian
all right dude why are you acting like
you just met her you [ __ ] married her
and he goes and i finally decided that i
don't believe in any of it oh that's why
oh well dude welcome to enlightenment
you know you can't throw it all out the
window but you know the seven deadly
sins
the ten commandments all that [ __ ] makes
sense but all that other stuff you know
burning bush talking to a bat that's
walking on a [ __ ] lake i mean come on
i mean are we adults here or what you
know
you have to throw your first baby over a
cliff to show that you love me
hey i was just [ __ ] with you you
passed the tell what the what is that
booming voice coming from the clouds
you know i just don't buy it something's
coming back like
for the love of god what what is it
waiting for
you know what i mean is jesus like
thurman thomas trying to find his
[ __ ] helmet
during the super bowl is that was that
what's going on here um
that's two thurman thomas references two
weeks in a row you find another [ __ ]
podcast that does it three weeks in a
row and goddammit you should stop
listening to this one
um anyways he says i finally decided
that i don't believe in any of it
i thought about telling her the old joke
we're both atheists
i just believe in one less god than you
do uh but she wouldn't find that funny
at all
she is okay she she's she is okay for
now
going to church without me because i
work nights but
i have a feeling that when the kids get
a little older
that i will have to become more involved
should i tell her now
or just let it be and hope that it never
comes up
well i have to tell you sir if you do in
fact
have the greatest wife in the world
she'll accept you for who you are
and if you're an atheist and you don't
believe
in the stuff that she believes in
then you know there you go this is what
i would do
let her let her take him to church
i i don't know what to do you know be
funny what if you took up needlepoint
okay and when you went to church you
just did needlepoint with your legs
crossed in the most effeminate way
possible maybe that's the way you do it
like some passive-aggressive way
that you so embarrassed the most
wonderful wife in the world that she
asks you not to come
you know what if you do like a
needlepoint that just
is like little atheistic sayings and you
make pillows
and when they have like the church drive
like the bake sale and they wash your
car you sell
you sell the pillows that you sow during
the mess
oh you know what and they say jesus is
lord
but it's almost like like one of those
pink floyd songs that if you if you play
it
i don't know if you listen to something
like hidden messages or something or
or maybe they never did maybe just these
jesus freaks did that's that'll really
freak them out
it may have like subtle messages in like
the the outskirts of the pillow
about this is all a bunch of [ __ ]
and uh you don't believe in pedophilia
you know
no jesus i'll give you some [ __ ]
emails um anyways what did he ask should
i tell her now or just let it be and
hope that it never comes up
um you're basically saying should i
should i man up and be who i am or
should i stick my head in the sand
okay that's that those are your two
options so i i'm going to throw this
back at you sir what kind of man do you
want to be
do you want to be the kind of man that
sticks his head in the [ __ ] sand when
there's a confrontation
or you want to be that guy that just
sits down and just says listen
sweetheart
i tried i just don't i don't believe it
okay and i think it's great that you
believe it
if you want to go down there and sing
the songs shake some hands
close your eyes right make a pledge for
jesus whatever the hell you want to do
you go down there and you do that
all right it's like watching football i
like doing it you know
you know you're not into it you know i
don't i don't make you watch football do
i
i don't do that you know why because i'm
the greatest husband in the world
let's try that just ask her
listen wait does she know
she always she knows that you're not
going
ah jesus you know what you might want to
give her a little jesus juice
uh get a little liquored up i don't want
to you know what dude
you got you got to tell her
you know i don't like how you're
deliberately working i feel like you're
deliberately working late on sundays
or early on sundays whenever the hell
she goes so you so you can just avoid
this you're avoiding [ __ ] sir
and this is a snowball all right
a snowball of jesus and it's rolling
right down towards you and at some point
it's gonna roll over you you know and
there's gonna be some [ __ ] creep
in church like that priest on the
[ __ ] sopranos that's going to come
over and [ __ ] hold her hand when
you're out there doing
your little job there all right so i say
you just tell her
just say i just look just be don't be a
douche just say i totally respect
i mean i'm [ __ ] around because i
gotta make this [ __ ] funny i don't care
if you believe in that [ __ ] god bless
you
you know you know what i hope you're
right so you can laugh at me
um when we all die um
that's so really i'm going to hell for
the rest of my [ __ ] for the rest of my
life you don't think that's a little
overkill
i think the rockefeller laws are [ __ ]
bad anyways um yeah just say look i
respect that you're into that type of
stuff and
listen you know what dude who gives a
[ __ ] somebody took you to church
somebody took you to church and you
after a while
realized that you didn't believe in it
so if she wants to take the kids to
church
just let her take him to church but your
wife has to be okay with the fact that
that they say yeah
how come you don't go down and pray to
the hippie you can say because i don't
believe in that stuff
i don't think it happened okay in a
couple of years
you'll understand what i mean when i
tell you about old saint nick
when i tell you the real story you know
there you go
santa claus for adults every sunday all
right
bill do i go for it hey billy fat face
uh love the podcast boo i need your
opinion on something
so like a typical douchebag i always
joke with my wife about having butt sex
he goes just because it makes her
uncomfortable dude but sex
is one of the funniest [ __ ] words
ever
because it's it's it's a butt
sex it's it it's really [ __ ] it
almost
you know it's almost the sound effect of
you pulling out
butt sex you know or going in that's
disgusting i'm so much more disgusting
on this thing than i am in my regular
podcast i'm in my regular act
but uh yeah butts butt sex it's really
like blunt force
kind of trauma there can you hear every
time i shift on the couch
so [ __ ] well miked here um he goes
anyways the other day she offered to try
it
if i quit saying [ __ ] and using the
lord's name
in vain for a month honestly
i never thought about trying it except
in high school with the chick
using the anal virgin loophole
should i go for it thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
um no no you shouldn't
okay and not because i'm some purist and
i'm saying you shouldn't bang your wife
in the ass
okay that's your legal property you can
do with it what you want
[Laughter]
i'm just [ __ ] with you no you
shouldn't you know why you shouldn't
because you have to do some sort of
[ __ ] parlor trick
hey if you jump through these [ __ ]
three hoops
you know then you can have a cookie go
[ __ ] yourself
go [ __ ] yourself see and it's too late
to say that
you know if you if you don't put your
shoes on the rug
maybe you can yeah you know what
maybe if you paid for the nfl package
i'll let you ride me
how about that why do they always act
like what they have
is so much better than what the [ __ ] you
have
you know why because we're weaker we're
like the fat guy who can't resist a
cookie and they're sitting over there
eating [ __ ] salad laughing at us
you know what you need to do sir you
need to get in control of your dick you
got to get your [ __ ] dick in check
okay this is one thing for you and for
everybody else
list every other guy listening to this
don't ever do a [ __ ] party trick for
a sexual favor go [ __ ] yourself
all right i'm not a goddamn chimp that's
what you gotta do just rub one out
rub one out and then you're not gonna
give a [ __ ]
you know what she should have said if
she said it if when the second
she said she'll uh she'll offer to try
it see right there all that means is
you're not gonna say
[ __ ] for a month and you're not gonna
say god damn jesus christ
it's goddamn [ __ ] thing jesus christ
it doesn't work you'll not be able to
say that for a month
just so you can sit there and for
[ __ ] eight
eighth of a second before she goes
[Music]
and then that's it and then you're gonna
go jesus christ
right and then she's going to sit there
and be like
oh so you're just going to go back to
saying that you know i thought it was
really nice
that you didn't say that like a whole
month right and now you're [ __ ] in
that
you know what it is it's like you get
you gave up you gave up that real estate
okay just like the native americans
just like the mexicans once you lost
texas you know what you have to do you
know what mexicans have to do to get
that [ __ ] thing back do you realize
the level of bloodshed
that they have to [ __ ] to ever get
that back
okay this is the same thing in the
[ __ ] this is the louisiana purchase
right here you're never getting it back
if you [ __ ] sit there and act like a
goddamn poindexter for a month and don't
talk
like how you normally talk just so you
can just
basically uh knock on the door of her
butthole to have a go
right i love how you
have to do the entire thing that she
wants just so she can attempt
to maybe do what you want see what you
see what happened
all right now you get a pass on this one
because this is your first time at the
rodeo so you missed it this time but the
next time
she does some [ __ ] like that i'll use
this one as an example
i'll let you do that if you know if
you're just trying to not say [ __ ]
and use the lord's name in vain for a
month you know what you should have said
you should have said sweetheart i love
you but
[ __ ] that okay and get out of the way
the goddamn tv
[Laughter]
and in a weird way she'd respect you
more
she'd respect you more you know what
dude you ought to be able to finesse
your way
into that [ __ ] move into that that
that that act
at this point all right you ought to be
able to talk your way into it
you ought to be able to make her want to
do it at this point all right
stop looking for the [ __ ] pass
interference call so you get the first
down why don't you [ __ ] earn it i'm
like half the [ __ ] quarterbacks in
the league these days
all right okay sorry that was tough love
but you needed it
dude she did everything but make you put
a [ __ ] red nose on
um pink boxing gloves jesus christ built
i was watching the boxing match between
adrian broner and antonio dimarco
and they both have pink gloves broner is
wearing pink shorts
it's [ __ ] november 18th i don't know
if you're into boxing well the way i try
to pronounce their names you can tell
them you know what it is
i love boxing but uh it's on saturday
nights and i'm always working so i miss
it
um
jimmy dore the great jimmy dore he
always orders the fights and he always
you know once every 10 fights i'm in
town i'll try and go over there and
watch him he's a big
big fight fan and a phenomenal comic one
of my favorites all right
um he says i don't know if you're into
boxing but i know that if you watch this
match
you would have been furious i'm not you
know i don't give a [ __ ]
i just it's
i just think you know you can just see
the writing on the wall
with all this pink [ __ ] eventually
there's going to be
a real sports segment or there's going
to be a 60 minute segment i'm calling it
right now like paul versi
that there's going to be some big
[ __ ] thing about how much
goddamn money these corporations made
off of off of um all this pink stuff
that they made off this horrific uh
disease
you know what i mean that five five-hour
energy
a portion of the proceeds yeah how how
much of a portion
how much of the portion goes to fighting
breast cancer and how much goes to
your [ __ ] yacht huh they had tassels
on your [ __ ] shoes
you know you know i love about that pink
it's just a raising awareness why don't
you [ __ ] tell us how not to get it
you know from what i've been reading
lately is what you want to do is you
want to eat some of the uh some of the
power foods there
you know like kale a lot of those leafy
greens bok choy and all that type of
things they're full of [ __ ] nutrients
and they actually help repair your cells
before they go all the way over into a
cancerous cell can you believe i have
the [ __ ] balls
to talk about something this medical do
you realize i'm just sitting here
that i got three quarters away through
that sentence before i actually realized
like wow
i am in way over my [ __ ] head i don't
even own a lab coat
i've just been reading that book uh um
eat for life
and i gotta tell you dude i
actually i'm believing in this because
i've tried i did the abs diet i've done
all those [ __ ] diets the pie
protein low carbs i've done all of that
[ __ ] and every time i was on those i
always had
cravings like [ __ ] miss bread
[ __ ] i want ice cream [ __ ] that's what
they should call those diets
you know but this thing here
filling up with fiber it's been
ridiculous
it's actually easy to do i have a banana
for breakfast
then i wait like an hour and then i have
an apple then i'm good till lunch
then i sit down and i have a giant
[ __ ] salad
and it fills me up i feel great throw
some beans on there and i'm good
i gotta tell you something you eat like
that you'll never be constipated ever
eat like a rabbit you will [ __ ] like a
horse
trust me trust me if you see those shows
without that [ __ ] lady you are what
you eat
supposed to be a meal in in a meal out
i was like what are you talking about i
ate three meals a day you're gonna tell
me i'm gonna [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] uh
at the end of the night i got a six spot
posting up a six
the triple double of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you telling me that that's gonna happen
i'm telling you if you [ __ ] eat like
that it's gonna happen
it's gonna happen i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm talking about but uh i
i have i
actually for once i'm starting to read
up on nutrition and uh
all right give give that book a read let
me know what you think
by the way there's no advertising on the
podcast this week none whatsoever
i'll tell you why at some point um
all right bill how much weight do i need
to lose to be [ __ ]
oh jesus uh all right just
saying that you're europe decent looks
here we go dear bill uh big fan of yours
go [ __ ] yourself
that was perfect a little compliment and
an uppercut i liked it
he goes i'm a fat ass
i'm 6'1 and used to weigh 400 pounds
as of january 2010. i've lost weight
with little effort on my part
and now weigh 337 pounds basically i
lost weight by giving up
soda adopting a one animal prop product
meal philosophy and exercising two to
three days a week at the gym
congratulations dude that's awesome
i got a charge out of that that's great
you're turning itself around good for
you
he goes i currently work at satan's
[ __ ]
walmart uh i will talk about them in
another email oh dude by all means
by all means hey all you people working
for these giant corporations if you're
seeing some seedy [ __ ]
by all means send it to me i'd love to
read the stories or
if you're actually doing some good [ __ ]
and you want to bring down my paranoia a
little bit i'll read the good [ __ ] too
all right the good [ __ ] [ __ ] douche
uh my schedule with them doesn't allow
me to get much exercise
in this time of year so increasing my
exercise ain't a possibility ain't
possible till january
this question is for the lovely mia
ah well she's not here right now
and i [ __ ] you guys over last week
because i didn't have time to do a uh
a neolog anyways uh he says how much
how much weight would i have to lose to
be [ __ ]
i got a john goodman patton oswalt like
potato face i
didn't want to trash pat and i didn't
know you're going to say that um
sorry pat one of the best [ __ ] comics
out there absolute beast
there we go sorry i don't read these
till i read
my apologies uh here's a link to my
facebook picture with my skinny brother
let her see her remember i am lazy i
want the bare minimum to be [ __ ] why
i gotta go with this one now
here we are in faith ah jesus christ
dude
all right hang on a second let's look at
this here there's your brother
all right dude how much weight do you
have to lose
all right the first thing you got to do
is get some contacts all right lose
those glasses
i like how you dressed you got a nice
suit on i would say
uh
get you in the game what'd you say 337
dude you know i gotta tell you something
but if you get down to 275
do you get down to 275 yeah you're six
one 275 you're your football weight
you'd be fine 275 you could carry that
and then just keep going get down like
230 you'd be good
i'd keep rocking the suits i'd lose the
glasses or you know what i would do if
you if you like if you don't like
contacts
get a uh get a hipper more uh
you know i'm judging your your [ __ ]
souffle kind of glasses you know this
doesn't that they wear on tv you could
turn it around you're right there dude
you're within 50 [ __ ] pounds but uh i
wouldn't use uh the holidays as an
excuse not to lose weight dude
just um you know what here's one for you
get that [ __ ] book um
uh eat to live
get that book eat to live just read the
first hundred pages of it you'll get the
gist of it and i'm telling you start
turning yourself around you start losing
[ __ ] weight
without even having to go to the gym all
right
he said remember i am lazy i want the
bare minimum
to be [ __ ] dude you know something
you got going for you got a great sense
of humor too
you get down to 275 all right
and you're funny and you're a warm guy
and you wear a suit
i'm telling you it's going to start
happening for you
all right you send me the [ __ ] email
about walmart and when you start getting
laid i want to know what the number was
all right okay where are we now how many
[ __ ] minutes are
47 minutes jesus christ i'm coming up
short this week
uh overrated underrated uh overrated
making the bed
throughout my entire life i've noticed
i've not once voluntarily
voluntarily made the bed i see it as a
pointless trivial task that makes
that serves no other purpose but to
please other people with ocd by giving
them a sense of completion
why spend even more than a minute of my
day
to fix something i'm going to mess up in
14 hours anyways
if i did my math correctly people spent
an average of 81 days worth of time
making the bed in their life kim
kardashian's marriage
lasted shorter than that what a waste of
time
if you if you're living alone look at
this type
be any smaller here if you're living
alone you're
made out to believe making the bed is a
necessary must do thing right next to
showering and brushing your teeth
who am i trying to impress if nobody
else is around
even if people are around to see it what
does it matter it's not like i don't
have a clean house does making my bed
alone really determine my cleanliness to
others
what's next tying our shoes after taking
them off
that's actually a good analogy perhaps
organizing our trash before throwing it
away it's just ridiculous
you know what i get a lot of that but
you know something coming home to a bed
that's made can also make you feel good
and also who knows you go out to
applebee's just to go out and get
yourself some mozzarella [ __ ] sticks
right and all of a sudden you you hook
up with some chick you bring her home
i'm telling you
she's like what am i doing with this
strange guy his [ __ ]
apartment smells maybe a little weird
i'm telling you a messed up bed can be a
deal breaker
girls look at a messed up bed they
probably think you [ __ ] [ __ ] all
over everything or banged another broad
and there next thing you know
she's got a half a foot out the door you
know but i do say i do see what you're
saying and i never make the bed but i
gotta tell you when i do make the bed
when i do come at night and the bed is
made i it actually makes me feel good
you know how many times have you lost
something in the bed
your cell phones under a pillow right
you lose your shoehorn some other
[ __ ] thing that nobody uses anymore
um youtube bama fans
oh i gotta see this i didn't even watch
this youtube video of the week
i want to see this is it a bunch of hot
chicks with that great [ __ ]
this video is no longer available due to
copyright claim
ah [ __ ] crap bar true barstool sports
was going to have that they're like
always on the cutting edge of all the
sports
stuff that you want you know what i have
that guy as a guest
way back in the day um so anyways where
the [ __ ] am i gonna be coming up
50 minutes in watch me kill somehow kill
50 minutes
why do i feel like i'm required to give
you an hour you know
wait a minute you're working a short
week you're only working till wednesday
why do i gotta put in a full [ __ ]
hour you know
you know why because i'm a solid [ __ ]
guy
i'm not a solid guy i just have a
[ __ ] need to be liked that's what it
is
i'm gonna be at the um
at the uh the improv in brea california
let me see if i can get to my [ __ ]
website this where the hell am i get to
my [ __ ] website here
shows shows for the week here i'm going
to be
my last gig of the year my last official
one
i'm going to be at the improv in brea
california
uh november 30th december 1st
and december 2nd and i highly recommend
you go to these shows because uh
i'm in a great mood lately and my act is
uh
is firing on all cylinders i got more
than enough
you know i was afraid because i retired
the steve jobs bit because i did it on
the
uh night of too many stairs
did you guys watch that clip did i send
you a a clip of that
um did i send a link to that i should
say
um can you hear me clicking here my
stomach [ __ ] growling
um i'm gonna try and find this for you
right here
anyways but if you get a chance to watch
it it's knighted too many stars
just go on youtube search that 90 too
many stars what the [ __ ] is my stomach
doing
nothing too many stars uh bill burn
you'll find it on youtube and uh i never
i gotta thank robert schmeichel
because he uh he fought for that set
because there were some people that were
nervous because i was trashing steve
jobs
and on that network apple advertises
which is a logic that's one of those
corporate decisions that doesn't bother
me
i i understand that i'm [ __ ] with
their money
but uh robert schneider really uh stuck
up for me on that one
fought for the set so uh if you see it
you like it
he's the reason why listen to my stomach
let's see if it'll do it
can you hear it come on i'll probably
have to bring it down really quickly
um oh you know what i'm doing this week
i'm going to my 25 year
[ __ ] high school reunion
there it is did i get it down there on
time did you hear a growling i'm
25 year [ __ ] high school reunion i
haven't been to any of them yet
because i felt like a loser
um you know what i mean
so i'm actually going to go back there
with a couple of my old drinking buddies
and i'm really looking forward to seeing
everybody there and i'm just hoping that
i'm i'm able to have uh
you know i really chose a different road
you know most of the people obviously
that i know including the guys i'm going
with they got married they had kids
you know they got the house with the
picket fence they did that type of [ __ ]
and
uh so i'm just hoping that it's not
going to be like so you're a comedian oh
that's awesome all right
and then everybody's just going to talk
about their kids and i'll be sitting
there with my [ __ ] hands in my
pockets like yeah
so you know i think i left something in
my
rented geo you know it's pretty
confident move huh i'm showing up in a
[ __ ] rented economy car
do you know i met some douche one time
this [ __ ] lady
and she had gone she'd grown up in my
town
i she was a little bit older and uh
i met her at one of my shows
and she was talking about how she had
recently gone to a high school reunion
and just was talking about how pathetic
everybody in her class was
and how um she only stayed there for two
hours before she left and went back to
the ritz carlton
in downtown boston before boarding her
united
flight back to colorado i never forget
that she used all the
names of every corporation that she was
involved in
the ritz carlton in boston boarding my
united airlines flight
you know and it was [ __ ] up because as
far as i could tell from talking to her
all she did in life was marry a rich guy
you know she's sitting there looking
down on these [ __ ] people i just you
know
united airlines i like how she said that
like it was the [ __ ] concord going to
back to paris
i don't know i just hope it's not i
don't think it's gonna be like that i
actually
came up with a really cool grade
it was crazy the great above me and the
grave below me
were uh they were everybody in my uh
and my my high school were cool but they
were
psychos the great above me and the grade
below me
they just fought like they were [ __ ]
maniacs
every weekend there was some bench
clearing brawl
and a party somebody gets a bottle
smashed over their [ __ ] head there
was like
lawsuits there was a dude in the great
above me
you want to talk about party tricks his
thing was he would eat a light bulb
and he'd be just sitting there eating it
with his gums bleeding he'd be smiling
his blood is in between his teeth like
[ __ ] maniac
okay how do you combat that it's [ __ ]
nuts
but my grade was mellow we were just
like
what was cool about migraine was when
you know suburban [ __ ] everyone would
end up going drinking in the woods
and everybody had that click and with
each year
the clicks just sort of started you know
you know coming together like a virus
but in a good way
and by the end of it everybody was kind
of hanging out with each other
you know we go we used to go to this
place this industrial park that wasn't
not developed yet and we would go down
there and there was a bunch of burned
out cars
back in the day when you could just burn
cars for [ __ ] insurance
and uh
and nobody would do it you know there
was no [ __ ]
i don't know just seen they didn't even
investigate it yes
i got a [ __ ] had a 74 pinto
yeah i can't believe somebody stole it
either it's unbelievable then they give
you money
insurance fraud was really easy back
then and that and then during those days
but anyways we used to drink down there
and uh it's [ __ ] that's all we do we
just everyone could come down in your
cars
and you see somebody's headlights coming
in and everyone would be like is that a
cop is that a cop
and there was always the people the
experts recognizing the silhouette of
the car and like the
uh the square headlights back then it
was the uh the crown vic
and the 85 crown vic that had a very
unique look to it
and that wasn't aerodynamic at all and
you could just tell and everyone would
[ __ ] screw
hide the beers all the [ __ ] we were
drinking so um
i don't know so i i haven't gone to any
of the uh reunions that from a feeling
like a loser and then i also had kind of
a paranoia where
i i i so liked everybody in my grade
i didn't want to come back and see
somebody not doing well i didn't want to
see somebody with the [ __ ]
gallbladder problem
or somebody divorced or just somebody
you know i wanted to remember everybody
the way i remembered them
everybody in my grade was [ __ ]
hilarious they had that light in their
eye
they had their whole [ __ ] lives ahead
of them so um
i guess that's the thing that i'm the
most nervous about i just want
i want to go back and see like happy
people
you know i don't want to see somebody
who [ __ ] up their back
and now they can't work and their
[ __ ] jobs [ __ ] with them i'm just
really hoping that that's going to be
you know there's the ups and downs in
life but i'm really hoping that that's
going to be to a [ __ ] minimum
a minimal a minimum you know am i nuts
do you guys actually you know do you
guys have any high school reunion
stories
i want to hear some good ones some
nightmare ones
uh and that type of [ __ ] just to you
know keep the podcast rolling here maybe
a different direction at some point
um anyways that's all i got i i could
really [ __ ] hang in here for another
[ __ ] round and take a couple
concussions that are going to [ __ ]
catch up with me later on in life i
don't want to do that leave the cops on
a um
a police chase or some [ __ ] thing
whatever oh by the way before we're
playing the dirty stinking jets
this week uh the very quiet jets
i guess somebody was [ __ ] all over
the jets this year i can't [ __ ] on the
jets they've had so many [ __ ]
injuries
i think it's actually amazing that
they're uh that they're four and six
and uh what's his face rex ryan hasn't
been talking [ __ ]
and there's something funny about seeing
him and uh
that guy there uh uh tony serrano
with his witness protection hat and
glasses i know his eyes got something
going on with his eye that's why he got
away there's just something funny about
them i was watching the game today
before we switched over to the knicks
and i saw the two of them standing there
like high-fiving and hugging each other
after a touchdown i just started
laughing i said to versi i go
they look like two [ __ ] guys who were
just about ready to walk into a casino
you know those guys that walk into a
casino still haven't learned the lesson
that they're going to lose they come in
like rubbing their hands
like they got a system that's what they
look like they look like two guys if
they were in like a buddy movie you'd
[ __ ] root for them so uh i don't know
i i don't know i've kind of lost my hate
when someone's not talking [ __ ] anymore
i i don't give a [ __ ]
is that weird i don't know go [ __ ]
yourselves that's a podcast for this
week okay
um nhl i'm sorry
i waited too damn near december i i need
another sport
um to offset when football's not on so i
don't know what to tell you i'm getting
the lead pass
uh i don't think you should take two
weeks off and you know what
people out there who blaming the players
it's not the player's fault
this is a lockout this is the owners the
owners are basically saying that we
don't agree with what we agreed with to
already a couple years earlier that's
such a [ __ ]
like it's such it's so so what the so if
the players really don't have an
agreement unless the agreement totally
works out for the owners
is that what it is you know what i mean
this is what the nfl owners did last
year
oh wait a minute that agreement that we
agreed to we don't agree with anymore so
we're taking our stadiums and going home
um unless you agree to our [ __ ]
demands i don't know i side with the
players on this one
and i really hope that they uh that they
can work it out because um
i miss it i was watching this thing on
hbo they were running this thing on the
uh
i was just [ __ ] up because i keep
leaning back and coming forward i hope
this isn't messing with the recording
too much
but i um i watched this thing on the
broad street bullies
and uh i have a love hate even though it
was before my time i have a love hate
for that whole
that whole [ __ ] team just because i
always loved the fighting
because that's what was going on when i
got into hockey but also
you know that style of play really set
the game back for a long
long [ __ ] time to to the point
that people to to this day when they
criticize hockey and when you listen to
them talk about it you would think it
was the mid
70s or early 80s like they don't even
[ __ ] watch it
and uh i don't know do you ever see that
whole thing about when the russians
came over here to play the nhl basically
i guess they were playing four
exhibition games and everybody knew that
they were the [ __ ]
it's canada's game and uh you know the
cold war was in full effect
and it was basically like um
we wanted to beat these guys you know it
was like saying that capitalism was
right and communism was wrong
so the russians came in and played three
top teams
and beat all of them so it was down to
the flyers to beat him
and the flyers to their credit their
coach actually came up with the system
which seemed like the lock of the trap
and they just [ __ ]
they slowed him down and the russians
couldn't figure it out and once they had
that going they started playing flyer
hockey
which is i really feel where they made
their [ __ ] mistake
they shouldn't have done that they
should have just beat him straight up
but basically they started throwing
elbows to the faces slashing at him and
doing all this type of [ __ ]
and the final one was some [ __ ] guy
in the fly escapes out of the penalty
box
and just [ __ ] elbows this guy right
in the face
and the guy goes down and it's not that
he did it it was that there was no call
so then the russian guy calls his
players off the ice
and says all right [ __ ] it that's it
we're going home and i then they were
showing the flyers and the guys going so
you
quit you take your players off the ice
like this guy's a [ __ ] and it's like
now
he's not a [ __ ] it's like we [ __ ]
played you straight
up and we beat you three [ __ ] times
in a row
we're better than you even if you win
tonight
we won three out of four and we proved
that we were we were better
during that time the russian team was
[ __ ] better so the only way you can
[ __ ] beat him
is to basically cheat and play dirty
i i think it was [ __ ] up but but the
russians came back out and they ended up
losing and
uh i don't know i don't want to be
un-american here but i got to side with
the russians on that one i think it was
[ __ ] up so i imagine i'm going to hear
from a bunch of [ __ ] angry flyer fans
but
i've never liked that [ __ ] i've never
liked it i don't mind
a goon fighting a [ __ ] goon but i
never liked that [ __ ] in hockey was just
like all right let's do some old
samuelson [ __ ]
i'm not as good as you uh maybe i'll
just jump on your [ __ ] knee
and then for some reason then they do
that they happy i hate them buddy
lasagna they even love them i never got
into that but i think it's [ __ ] but
i do respect
the the flyers to a certain extent and
their fan base but i i i thought that
that one was [ __ ] up you should you
had the game plan you [ __ ] you should
have just beat him straight up
all right i had to put that one to bed
i had to give you my opinion on a
[ __ ] game that happened 37 [ __ ]
years ago
all right that's the podcast i would i
do i went over an hour during the
holiday weeks that's it everybody have a
wonderful thanksgiving
uh you know try to get along with your
relatives
don't take the bait okay you can't
change the past you you can't change
them
all right all you can do is change the
future by uh
by what you create okay so there you go
man
that's the most hippie thing i've ever
[ __ ] said i'm trying to be a little
more positive
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
i'll talk to you next week
you